personne ou presque n'aurait parié sur
lui pour devenir le Président de la
première puissance mondiale et pourtant
comme vient de nous le rappeler ce
documentaire réalisé par Cédric Condon
et tiré de la série les coulisses de
l'histoire une fois élu Ronald rigane a
fini par bluffer tout son monde tout
d'abord en incarnant avec margarte tcher
le néolibéralisme des années 80 et
ensuite en mettant un terme à plus de 40
ans de guerre froide avec l'Union
soviétique et pour débattre de ce
scénario écrit et réalisé par l'ancien
acteur durant ces 8 années passées à la
Maison Blanche trois invités sont
maintenant avec nous sur ce plateau de
des badoog nicole Bacharan pour
commencer bienvenue à vous nicole
Bacharan vous êtes politologue
spécialiste de la société américaine on
vous doit entre autre les grands jours
qui ont changé l'Amérique coécrit avec
le journaliste Dominique Simonet et
publié aux éditions Périn quant à votre
dernier livre plus personnel hein
celui-là puisqu'il mêle l'intrigue roman
qui est votre propre cheminement sur les
traces de votre mère et bien il
s'intitule la plus résistante de toutes
et cet ouvrage et disponible chez Stock
Jean-Luc s est également avec nous
bienvenue Jean-Luc vous êtes journaliste
ancien patron du groupe Radio France
vous étiez correspondant à Washington
c'était pour France Inter à l'époque
dans les années ran autrement dit bien
sûr les années 80 et vous êtes par
ailleurs l'auteur de nombreux ouvrages
consacrés aux États-Unis dont celui-ci
le dernier l'Amérique la facture le
monde peut-il encore faire confiance à
l'Amérique point d'interrogation la
réponse est dans ce livre et il est
disponible chez beaker Street édition
puis enfin axel pionetovski est avec
nous bienvenue vous êtes ancien député
UMP puis les républicains du valdoise en
région parisienne bien sûr ancien
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de l'Assemblée nationale très
bon connaisseur des États-Unis vous avez
d'ailleurs été à nombreuses reprises le
président du groupe d'amitié France
États-Unis ici à l'Assemblée nationale
nicole Bacharan on a donc revu avec ce
film ce qui a été le parcours la
carrière de de d'orinal Ran le bluffant
Ronald ran c'est le thème de ce de ce
documentaire quel côte a-t-il encore
aujourd'hui Ronald Rean en 2023 du côté
des États-Unis plutôt bonne en fait
plutôt bonne on a je crois qu'on a
oublié ses faiblesses et qu'on on se
souvient d'un homme très élégant très
classe sans la moindre vulgarité qui n'a
jamais comment dire fait honte qui n'a
jamais fait honte à son pays qui à la
fin de sa carrière s'est retiré avec
beaucoup de dignité justement puisque il
était malade et il a glissé lentement
vers vers le passé et qu'au fond c'était
quand même on l'a vu c'est des années
qui ont été très difficiles pour
certains mais où il avait ramené une
forme une forme d'optimisme de foi en
l'Amérique et puis il est quand même
considéré comme celui qui a qui a a
gagné la guerre froide donc étant donné
la suite de président qu'on a pu avoir
depuis sa côte est plutôt bonne Ronald
Rean son parcours
d'acteur il est parti de rien Ronald
Rean ensuite il a été acteur durant 27
ans hein avec d'ailleurs une une
filmographie tout à fait respectacle
hein 62
longmétrages une cinquantaine de
téléfilms c'était toujours un acteur de
sérib mais enfin tout de même il a
compté dans ces années-là c'était en
entre 37 et et
1964 tout ce parcours de Ronald Rean
aujourd'hui euh c'est une histoire qui
aime bien les Américains ce type de
parcours ça explique peut-être aussi
qu'aujourd'hui il garde une bonne côte
une bonne image du côté des améric je
pense que l'homme parti de rien et qui
arrive au sommet c'est quand même le
grand myth américain et même si il y a
très peu d'individus qui le réalisent il
y en a quand même suffisamment pour
qu'on puisse continuer euh à y croire
donc c'est vrai qu'il l'incarne il
l'incarne à merveille mais je je crois
que c'est ces années d'acteurs ces
années de représentants de commerce
aussi car ça a été un de ses Jobs
pendant ces temps là il a développé un
talent de communication et de séduction
inimaginable moi j'ai travaillé pendant
plusieurs années à l'Institut Hoover en
Californie qui est en gros d'origine
ranienne et ils ont énormément
d'archives et notamment les archives
radios et les causeries à la radio que
Rean
faisait pendant qu'il était président je
parle devant un homme de radio mais
c'est extraordinaire il il partait d'une
d'une anecdote tout à fait personnelle
il m'arrivait ça j'ai croisé mon chien
que sais-je et il vous amenait à un
développement économique ou politique et
à la fin avec cette voix chaude cette
manière de vous parler a qu'une très
grande proximité ben vous étiez d'accord
avec lui il a un talent fou il faut il
fallait pas le sous-estimer on va
repasser un premier extrait du film
c'est tout simplement le le slogan
utilis an nous sommes en 1980 à
l'occasion de la campagne pour la
présidence
américaine avec son slogan rest dans
l'histoire il conv les Américains qu'un
nouvel âge d'or est
[Applaudissements]
possible
ça rappelle tout simplement le le slogan
qui était celui de de Donald Trump bien
entendu c'est dommage enfin de mon point
de vue c'est tout à fait personnel mais
on parlait de Rean cet homme ce All
American boy c'est vrai il incarne
l'Américain parfait il était même gentil
avec sa femme il l'a jamais battu quoi
qu'il ait divorcé quand même ça c'était
pas bien mais il incarnait quelque chose
avec un humour fou une élégance je dis
toujours c'est le seul homme que j'ai
rencontré pendant 8 ans je l'ai suivi à
la Maison Blanche qui portait des
costumes marrons et ça lui allait
essayer de mettre un costume marron
c'est pas évident lui tout lui allait et
je et je dois dire aussi c'est très
rafraîchissant ce documentaire c'est un
beau documentaire parce que dans le
contexte où on vit nous ces temps-ci on
se dit c'était quand même assez
rationnel même avec ses défauts Rean il
travaillait pas beaucoup il il adorait
faire la sieste fallait pas ça vous
l'avez constaté tout ce qu'il dit dans
ce documentaire oui il travaillit pas
beaucoup avec des emplois un peu en
dilettant comme çaouou bon ça lui a
plutôt réussi on est je crois tous
d'accord sur sur le sujet il y a des
gens qui ont de l'intuition et il y a
des gens qui comprennent leur pays et
leurs concitoyens ce qui me semble
vraiment éblouissant chez Reagan quoi il
pouvait parler à tout le monde et les
gens croyaient qu'ils étaient estimés
par leur président il y avait une
empathie c'est pas si courant que ça
mais donc je trouve ça tellement
rafraîchissant par les temps qui courent
qu'on ait confiance dans dans celui qui
est leader de d'une grande nation il a
ses carences il a ses incapacités ses
machins c'est c'est défaut comme tout le
monde mais le résultat est là et ça
m'ennuie de vous dire ça parce que quand
je suis arrivé comme correspondant la
Maison Blanche j'ai passé 8 ans avec
Rean c'était pas franchement ma tasse de
thé intellectuellement je dis ça en
toute humilité mais j'étais plutôt genre
démocrate je suis toujours d'ailleurs et
puis j'aimais beaucoup Carter ce qu' l'
incarnait cette espèce de moralité un
peu un peu voilà un peu ultra un peu
trop moral mais j'ai fini il a fini par
me par Me conquérir ce vous fait vous
aussi finalement oui oui oui non mais on
peut pas le détester c'est juste pas
possible si on est un honnête h on peut
pas détester Rean quoi let's make
America gr again je reviens sur ce qui
était slogan tout de même de la campagne
de de
1980 donc la première campagne pour la
Maison Blanche de de Ronald Rean là en
ayant ce type de slogan il était
justement peut-être en phase avec la
population américaine pour revenir sur
ce qui vient d'être dit à cette époque
très précise de 1980 mais il l'était il
l'était en réalité beaucoup plus que
Trump ne peut l'être aujourd'hui avec le
même slogan parce que il faut bien se
rappeler qu'en 1980 les États-Unis
revenaent de loin la situation était
quand même extrêmement morose que ce
soit sur le plan économique vous aviez
une inflation à 14 % vous aviez 10 % de
chômeurs et puis que ce soit sur l'état
du pays c'était un pays déprimé il y
avait eu toutes les années Vietnam
d'ailleurs les Américains se demandent
encore qu'est-ce qu'ils sont allés faire
au Vietnam puis vous aviez eu le
Watergate année vraiment sordide en
réalité puis tombait en plein moment du
de la fin de l'affaire des otages de
l'ambassade américaine n'oubliez pas que
les otages ont été libérés le jour de
l'investiture de rigane donc suite
finalement à la négociation de autrement
dit en janvier Carter et vous voyez
c'est formidable parce que en
fait tout ça donne l'impression de cette
extraordinaire optimisme et et confiance
que Ran et que rigan a su dégager et
qu'il a su faire partager à ses à ses à
ses concitoyens parce que après ça vous
avez eu le rebond économique des
États-Unis avec un remède de cheval
ouais alors ça on va y revenir néanmoins
il incarnait le
conservatisme tel que l'a défendu par
ailleurs Trump sur les valeurs
sociétales par exemple il est pour la
peine de mort il est contre
l'avortement il est pour une très dur
face au syndicat c'est ça aussi Ronald
Rean non c'est ça aussi et c'est vrai
que notamment sur la question de de
l'avortement c'est lui qui a entamé ce
ce rapprochement des des républicains
avec les les
religieux très conservateur qui je dois
dire l'était quand même beaucoup moins
qu'aujourd'hui et c'est et même si Regan
a a pris des positions dures sur
l'avortement sur l'homosexualité sur la
question du sida par exemple parce que
ce sera ce seront aussi les années sida
il me semble qu'on l'en tenait pas
tellement rigueur qu'on avait pas le
sentiment c'était quelqu'un de méchant
qui voulait la la mort des femmes ou la
ou la mort du pêcheur alors que on a
glissé depuis vers une authentique
cruauté je trouve dans dans ces cercles
ultra brutalement religieux a j'ai envie
de dire donc c'est vrai qu'il y a eu des
il a glané des voix dans ces milieux-là
sans sans sans aucun doute mais c'est
c'est par la suite aller beaucoup plus
loin qu'on ne pouvait l'anticiper mais
c'est un homme complexe son idole céit
je ve dire jusqu'à la fin de ses jour
d'ailleurs he
Roosevelt grand président démocrate et
Rean était un démocrate jusqu'aux années
et alors comme il avait le sens de
l'humour il dit c'est pas moi qui a
changé c'est le parti démocrate c'est il
faisait toujours des des blagues comme
ça et je dois dire aussi que ça dit
beaucoup sur un homme politique de cette
stature quand on dirige des États-Unis
quel que soit le président tout de même
c'est c'est quelque chose c'est un
monument l'état quoi et il a le sens de
l'humour est désarmant chez lui ça veut
dire quelque chose encore une fois c'est
dans ce cette cette veine empathique
avec les gens on aime l'humour et c'est
pas un humour il avait vraiment le sens
de l'humour puis il avait aussi des gens
qui écrivaient Peggy nounan par exemple
écrivaient ses discours à la fin c'était
une une fée de de l'écriture mais ça
jouit beaucoup on lui pardonnait tout
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a appelé le
président tflon d'ailleurs on a inventé
le truc comme ça parce que il avait il
disait des trucs je me souviens de la
campagne électorale c'était face à
Mondel oui et donc il avait un certain
âge c'était pas papy il était en bon
état physique peut-être pas tout à fait
psychique le pauvre il avait des des
problèmes de santé de ce côté-là mais il
est il se tenait droit comme un i il
était mince il était cétait un bel homme
quoi franchement et donc je me souviens
du débat avec Walter Mondel qui éit le
candidat démocrate qui était beaucoup
plus jeune et donc il dit à un moment
Ragan il dit je ne vais pas utiliser
cette histoire de l'inexpérience et de
la jeunesse de mon adversaire pas en
politique truc comme ça mais je trouvais
tout le monde s'est marré même Mel et
c'est ça aussi Rean c'est du talent
politique vous nous ameniez sur le
terrain économique avec là pour le coup
un vrai tour de vis hein dans les
dépenses publiques deuxème extrait du
documentaire le président de la rupture
fait table race du
passé commence alors le démantelllement
des dispositifs régulant l'activité
économique pour stimuler la
compétitivité des dizaines de loi
disparaissent ainsi sont abolies les
normes d'encadrement des nouveaux
médicaments
l'obligation des inspections
quotidiennes dans les abattoirs ou
encore les seuils limites de contact des
ouvriers avec les matières
cancérigènes puis viennent les mesures
destinées à réduire le poids de l'État
20000 postes de fonctionnaires sont
supprimé et les réfractaires n'ont qu'à
bien se tenir alors cette politique elle
est dite riganomix elle repose à la fois
sur une forte baisse des impôts la
réduction drastique des des dépenses
publiques et surtout dans le domaine
social
dérégulation sur le plan des marchés
financiers là c'est vraiment la bascule
dans ce qu'on a appelé le néol
libéralisme et lui il y vient à la tête
des États-Unis un an après Margaret
toucher qui met en place la même
politique hein grosso modo du côté de la
Grande-Bretagne ça c'est vraiment la
rupture ah ben c'est clairement la
rupture et il y a eu beaucoup de
dérégulations aux États-Unis
probablement trop d'ailleurs que ce soit
sur les dans les domaines que vous
citiez mais également dans le domaine
bancaire qui a été un des plus graves
dans le domaine de environnement
également il y a eu trop de duligation
en
globalement l'impact économique a été
très largement positif si on fait le le
bilan du tout et d'ailleurs nous
Européens et le reste du monde en avons
largement profité parce que n'oublions
pas que les les premières mesures qu'il
a prise et qui qui ont été celles qui
ont conduite à retrouver la croissance
franchement partout ça a été la
politique monétariste qui a été menée
immédiatement avec Paul Volker qui était
à la tête de la Fed et où ils ont porté
les taux d'intérêt à 20% pour bon ce qui
a eu pour effet quoi d'abord une année
82 difficile mais après l'inflation est
passée de 14 à 3 % le chômage est passé
de 10 ou 12 % à 4 % autrement et et puis
la croissance économique est repartie
aux États-Unis et d'ailleurs elle est
repartie en même temps dans dans dans le
reste du monde les pays en voie de
développement ont payé la note aussi
tout de même quand les taux d'intérêts
ont Moné considérablement y compris la
France mais tout le monde a payé la note
à ce moment-là mais après les effets ont
été très largement positifs c'est vrai
que au départ ça étéit un remède de
cheval avec des inégalités sociales qui
se sont creusé c'est aussi une des
conséquences de cette politique qu'on a
appelé taxé
d'ultralibéral c'est l'autre versant de
la de la pièce c'est c'est une politique
qui est un petit peu pour les les jours
heureux pour les jours ensoleillés quand
l'économie tourne à à plein et
qu'effectivement le le chômage baisse la
croissance repart ça le le détricotage
du filet social ne ne saute pas aux yeux
immédiatement parce qu'il y avait encore
un État providence si on peut dire les
choses comme ça aux États-Unis lorsqu'il
arrive à la Maison Blanche c'est ça qu'
qui remet en cause en réalité quand
quand l'économie plonge il y a eu des
périodes de plongé et particulièrement
après Reagan c'est là qu'on s'aperçoit
qu'il y avait certains certaines
protections dont on dont on avait bien
besoin HM je pardon j'ai une petite
anecdote qui est très triste mais
c'était à Dallas à la gare routière des
greyhounds là des des bus c'était
quelques mois après l'arrivée de Rean et
on avait supprimé les crédits médicair
tout ça et on vidait les hôpitaux
psychiatriques c'estàdire qu'on on on
amenait des gens qui étaient
manifestement pas en très bonne santé
mentale pour qu'ils aillent rejoindre
leur famille leur donn un ticket de de
bus voilà il y en a qui allit à Chicago
l'autre Los Angeles et c'était
pathétique à à regarder donc que c'est
aussi quelque c'est un souvenir qui m'a
vraiment beaucoup marqué et je pense
aussi à l'économie comment elle est
perçu les États-Unis c'est pas la France
on est toujours content de gagner sa vie
et de de devenir riche c'est pas c'est
pas un crime quand on est américain quoi
mais je me souviens toujours d'un d'unun
dessin humoristique dans un journal je
sais plus lequel où on voyait il y avait
une soirée à la Maison Blanche contre le
racisme donc c'était Rean qui faisait un
discours le racisme c'est pas bien et
ils avaient invité Michael Jackson et
Michael Jackson disait je vous remercie
pour tout ce que vous avez fait pour
nous et Rean disait pour les riches et
donc ça il y avait cette espèce de folie
de l'argent à un certain moment oui et
ça peut ne pas déplaire aussi aux
citoyens américains je veux dire ils lui
ont pardonné ça comme ils lui ont tout
pardonné d'ailleurs quand vous dites
nous avons tous payé l'addition mais de
de quelle addition vous parlez tout on a
payé l'addition je dit on a tous profité
de la croissance ah tous profité de la
croissance regardez rappelez-vous les
années 80 ça a été des années de très
fort sorte croissant c'est intéressant
parce que on n pas payé une certaine
addition tout de même de ce côtélà de
l'Atlantique avec cette politique
ultraalibérale menée par à la fois Réal
et puis je l'ai dit toucher écoutez on a
nous enfin si vous voulez aller sur ce
terrain là on a on a surtout payé
l'dition des années mitteran parce que
malheureusement on n pas su profiter en
France tout au moins de cette de cette
croissance mais par exemple les
Allemands ou un certain nombre d'autres
pays on en profité beaucoup plus
intelligemment que ce que nous avons
fait mais pour revenir aux aspects
effectivement certains de ces aspects
étai étai très violents je pense pas que
rigan est quelqu'un qui a jamais fait
cela par méchanceté si vous voulez par
un espèce de goût de de de de différ
différenciation de classe et voyez j'en
veux pour preuve que il fait ça et en
même temps il régularise 3 millions de
travailleurs en situation irrégulière
excusez du peu non mais c'est
intéressant de voir au moment où on peut
être confronté à des situations
identiques alors vous me direz que
c'était des des des des travailleurs qui
avaient un job hein c'était pas des des
des des immigrés qui étaient qui étaient
sans travail mais pourquoi il le fait il
le fait pas pour la beauté de leurs yeux
il le fait tout simplement parce que les
États-Unis en ont besoin États-Unis en
ont besoin pour pouvoir poursuivre cette
croissance et cetera mais donc il sait
prendre des des des mesures qui sont des
mesures extrêmement pragmatiques même
quand ça va dans dans dans ce sens-là
c'est vrai que Rean est le dernier
président qui a réussi à faire passer
une réforme de l'immigration et avec
dans cette réforme de l'immigration
l'amnistie pour pour 3 millions
d'étrangers en situation irrégulière les
présidents qui se sont succédés depuis
ont tous essayé d'arriver à un système
sur l'immigration qui soit acceptable et
le blocage politique est tel que c'est
c'est c'est devenu totalement impossible
or c'est ce président conservateur
libéral et qui était pas incapable de
revenir il avait pas de position
dogmatique au fond il a effectivement
donc amnestié 3 millions d'étrangers il
a également remonter les impôts à un
moment les additions mont montré que ça
ne marchait plus et il nétait il n'était
pas bloqué sur les baisses d'impôts
comment dire dogmatique donc il il
pouvait changer changer de Brad ça
l'intéressait pas tellement non plus les
mécanisme économique et je comprends ça
je suis pas un économiste et c'est très
compliqué mais quand même la façon dont
il a touché aux impôts c'est très
intéressant parce que il l'a pas touché
à l'impôt sur le revenu qu'il a laissé à
un niveau extrêmement bas donc ça
profitait à toute la hiérarchie et en
revanche il a touché à l'impôt sur les
dividendes sur les plus-values sur les
successions oui oui non tout à fait qui
était un impôt qui était finalement un
impôt assez payé par les rifs quand même
non mais donc moi je mets dans la case
positive un homme qui sait qu'il ne sait
pas par exemple c'est vrai qu'il
s'ennuyait à mourir dans les réunions
budgétaires les trucs son truc c'était
mec il avait repris clintst W pour dire
si vous votez pas le budget attention me
myid enfin bon donc c'était pas un
monsieur qui allait avec beaucoup de
rigueur dans il s'ennuyait dans les
réunions tous les gens quientour ouis
donc il disait j'ai l'impression de
retourner à l'école c'est plus de mon
âge tout ça donc il comptait moi je
trouve aussi que je mets ça encore une
fois dans la case positive un homme qui
connaît ses limites et qui est
pragmatique donc d'ailleurs le résultat
est là oui mais je pense pas qu'il
fallait interpréter exactement comme ça
c'estes limite parce on dit souvent
c'est quelqu'un d'incompétent j'ai pas
dit ça je trouve que
c'est ou mais c'est parfaitement stupide
de dire ça parce que il avait une
intelligence moyenne normale moyenne il
était sûrement moins intelligent que
Carter et Nixon enfin faites le bil
faites le bilan des uns et des autres on
est d'accord oui c'est ça alors vous
l'avez dit président conservateur
président libéral et aussi président
viscéralement antiommuniste 3è et
dernier extrait du film il redoute une
attaque nucléaire lancée par l'empire du
mal il décide donc de militariser
l'espace d'armer les satellites d'un
rayon laser pour anéantir les missiles
ennemis pour l'occasion rigan oublie sa
paresse légendaire et monte au créneau
il passe des heures à tenter de
convaincre le Pentagone d'adhérer à son
projet les militaire hésitent non
seulement c'est un gouffre financier
mais sur le plan technique il relève
quasiment de la
science-fiction alors là nous sommes je
crois en mars
1983 et l'initiative de défense
stratégique l FS est présenté donc à
l'ensemble des Américains c'est un
programme militaire plus connu sous le
nom de gu ément la guerre des étoiles
sur les grands écrans américains et pas
seulement hein partout dans le monde
c'est un véritable coup de bluff euh
peut-être pour revenir avant sur ce qui
est dit dans dans ce film il aura certes
mis un terme à 40 ans de guerre froide
mais il aura relancé la guerre froide
dans un premier temps avec yri Andropov
qui a précédé Gorbatchev au kremelin
c'est quand même lui qui a pris cette
initiative de la lancer cette guerre
cette guerre froide avec ce spectre
d'une guerre des étoiles non alors là là
à mon à mes yeux mes humbles yeux je
pense qu'il a eu un coup de génie
vraiment et c'est cité dans le
documentaire pour lui sa vision de la
stratégie de la guerre froide c'était on
gagne et ils perdent et et c'était total
tellement révolutionnaire à l'époque
dans les fac on enseignait aux étudiants
que la différence entre une dictature de
droite et une dictature de gauche et ben
c'est que la dictature de droite elle
finissait par tomber une dictature
fasciste et que la dictature communiste
elle s'installait définitivement et
qu'on et qu'on en qu'on en verrait
jamais la fin et Regan là-dessus il a
été très cohérent pour lui c'était
vraiment l'empire du mal son d'ailleurs
il aurait été à peu près toutes les
luttes antiommunistes en Amérique
centrale euh et et en Amérique du Sud
notamment alors pas toujours au nom des
États-Unis hein parfois avec ça lui a
rapporté quelques ennuis sévères
d'ailleurs groupe ou la CIA mais voilà
ça c'est aussi sa marque de fabrique
hein l'anticommunisme absolument et à
mes yeux plutôt sympathique même si les
entreprises en Amérique
latine mériterait d'être revisité mais
c'est pas tout à fait notre sujet
aujourd'hui mais il a très il avait très
très bien compris que l'Union soviétique
était en difficulté que
relancer les programmes armement allait
provoquer chez les Soviétiques une
course pour rattraper et donc des
dépenses d'argent sur lesqueles il ne
pourraient pas suivre alors que le
projet de Reagan était il a réussi en
partie de justement de réduire
drastiquement les les armement nucléaire
il en a relancé le projet pour en
réalité réduire le leur réalité et il a
comment dire il s'est vraiment impliqué
dans la dans la chute du communisme
enfin il a a travaillé avec le le le
pape Jean-Paul II pour soutenir Solidar
notch en
polnerai activement du côté
de les prêtres polonais travailler
ensemble il a il a poussé les
Soviétiques vers la chute alors coup de
génie dit Nicol et sur quoi d'ailleurs
on sait pas très bien sur quoi reposait
ce coup de génie parce que techniquement
scientifiquement il y avait-il seulement
quelque chosees dans les non mais c'est
lui qui a lancé ça et même ses généraux
n'y croyaient pas parce qu'il savaiit
que c'était pas faisable mais sur le
fond la politique étrangère de rigane
pour nous Européens et nous Français
c'est vraiment le côté très très positif
de son bilan c'est la fin de l'empire
soviétique c'est la fin du communisme
c'est la fin de la guerre froide excusez
du peu et n'oubliez pas vous disait il
relançait il a relancé à un moment donné
les armements et cetera ce qu'il faut
pas oublier quand même dans ces années
84 85 86 c'est que le risque nucléaire
était très très
prégnant et et le terrain jeu du risque
nucléaire c'était l'Europe on a oublié
un petit peu toute cette période là mais
il faut surtout pas l'oublier et et je
pense que l'on doit pas uniquement à
rigane mais je pense qu'il a très
largement compliqué à éradiquer
complètement ce richque là
mais je vous rejoins tous les deux vous
avez dit génie c'est un coup de génie et
il y en a un aussi qui est d'accord avec
vous c'est comatchev gbatchov au départ
de de Reagan et la chute du mur de
Berlin il a dit c'est ce type il l'a pas
dit comme ça mais ce type a du génie et
les rencontres les différents sommets
auxquels j'ai pu partis enfin assister
pardon comme correspondant de la Maison
Blanche c'était étonnant la façon dont
Rean savait pas manœuvrer mais manier ce
qui était
l'URSS avec gorbachchov c'était quelque
chose de très frappant et il avait de la
chance d'avoir trouver un partenaire
comme Gorbatchev pour aller dans le sens
de du désarmement mais c'était étonnant
comme il était juste et donc on s'y
attendait pas toujours de la part de
Reagan quoi et il a il y a c'est un
parcours sans faute alors après bon il
faut être deux pour danser le tango
comme il disait mais mais il a réussi ça
et vraiment c'est c'est vrai que on lui
doit beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup vous
étiez à Washington lors de cette annonce
en 83 jean-lucas de de de cette guerre
des étoiles c'est le nom c'est le terme
qu'on qu'on lu a donné vous avez creusé
un peu qu'est-ce qu'il y avait derrière
concrètement ben il y avait pas
grandchose il y avait un conseiller
hongrois qui avait des comptes à régler
j'ai oublié son nom le docteur j'ai
oublié son nom qui était un conseiller
un proche de Regan donc avait réussi à
le convaincre il fallait en finir à tout
jamais avec le démon communiste donc
ilavait pas à creuser beaucoup dans le
cerveau de Rean pour le convaincre mais
c'est vrai que le Pentagone voyait ça
d'un œil un peu c'était le titre d'un
film de Reagan d'ailleurs la guerre des
étoiles si j'ai bonne mémoire et donc il
s les gens se disaient ça va pas trop là
ça ça va coûter un argent fou et puis
personne ne pensait en fait n'avait
regardé à quel point le monde communiste
était dévasté économiquement
financièrement et qu' pouvait pas
challenger l'Amérique donc lui il a
compris ça il a cru en ça et il a bien
fait d' croire parce que le mur de
Berlin est tombé quoi c'est il faut se
rendre compte de ce que c'était est-ce
qu'on se disait ça 4 ou 5 ans avant que
non on était en plein guerre de
l'Afghanistan enfin c'était il y avait
plein de soucis enfin c'était tendu la
guerre froide c'est pas n'importe quoi
c'est pas un mot videite de sens c'était
on a vécu pendant 40 ans avec ça est-ce
qu'il avait instauré réussi à instaurer
une relation personnelle je crois qu'il
croyait beaucoup au relations
personnelle hein entre entre chefs
d'État est-ce que c'était le cas avec
gorbatchef est-ce qu'on a trace de du
voilà d'une relation établie personnelle
entre les deux hommes il il a essayé
avec bregeenf pour commencer en lu
envoyant une lettre complètement
personnelle justement très belle sur la
ité le bonheur des peuples vous êtes un
homme raisonnable et cetera donc fin de
non recevoir le dramatique ensuite il y
a eu la succession pardonnez-moi si j'en
oubli tnenko Andropov tnenko et
finalement Gorbatchev et quand
Gorbatchev est arrivé la relation c'est
pas installé immédiatement mais Rean a
dit voilà je sais plus la formule mais
voilà voilà l'homme que
j'attendais un soviétique mais
intelligent moderne à qui je peux parler
de des choses essentielles au-delà de de
la division historique et et et
politique qui est qui est la nôtre et il
a réussi ça avec gorbatev mais il l'a
réussi aussi avec François mitteran
alors que la méfiance était immense au
départ a beaucoup reproché à François
mitteran d'avoir pris des des ministres
communistes notamment après son élection
8 pas confiance à Washington mais par
exemple il y a eu des grandes opérations
d'espionnage partagé entre Rean et
miteron directement et il y a eu
également mais l'affaire des PER
inst installé pour faire face à l'Union
soviétique face aux fusé soviéti qui
étit pointé vers l'Europe vous le disait
très justement le terrain de jeu c'était
quand même l'Europe et et là où miteran
a eu cette formule soutenant
Rean les les fusées sont à l'est et les
pacifistes sont à l'ouest oui est-ce qu'
est-ce qu'il avait est-ce qu'il y a eu
quelque chose entre mitterran entre
mitteran entre Ran et gorbachchev je
pense que oui je pense qu'il y a eu une
certaine vraie confiance qui s'établit
entre les deux et j'en veux pour preuve
le fait que quand ils ont signé le le
premier accord le premier traité de
désarmement qui portait sur les missiles
nucléaaires de courte portée de courte
et de moyenne portée accord de
Washington je crois c'est en 80 voilà et
bien la totalité de l'état-major et des
militaires américains et d'ailleurs des
universitaires ont déconseillé àigan de
le Sayer en disant vous allez trop loin
vous prenez trop de risque et moyen en
quoi il l'a quand même signé donc je
pense qu'il fonctionnait beaucoup au
feeling je pense qu'il a fonctionné
aussi au feeling avec mitteran et avec
miteran et miteran ça a été notamment
l'affaire fairwell faut pas l'oublier
voà exactement faut peut-être rappeler
rapidement à la toute fin de l'émission
que trouve se trouve que il se trouve
que vous aviez un espion russe qui est
officier sur le territoire enfin depuis
Moscou sur le territoire français et qui
a commencé à communiquer énormément
d'information à la DST France et
notamment tout le dispositif soviétique
dans en Occident au États-Unis en France
en Europe et cetera et et mit Teran qui
voulait donner des gages à harigane à la
suite de la domination des communistes
lors d'un des sommets du G7 je crois que
c'était à utawa a dit à miteran a dit à
à rigane écoutez on peut vous donner à
peu près le nom de 400 ou 500 espions
qui sont en train d'œevrer sur le
territoire américain alors là ran a été
complètement bluffé euh miteran a
communiqué tous les noms et à ce
moment-là il s'est établi de en effet
entre eux une certaine confiance ça sera
le le mot de la fin merci vraiment hein
Gorbatchev a assisté aux obsecs de oui
de Reagan il fallait le souligner c'est
vrai merci vraiment à tous les trois he
d'avoir participé à à cette émission des
Badog consacré à à l' Regan AR Rogel
regigan qui aura passé donc 8 ans à la
Maison Blanche entre
1981 et
vos réactions ça sera sur hashtag
debadoc merci à Selma sali et aussi à
Sarah eedoline qui m'ont aidé à préparer
cette émission je vous retrouverai bien
sûr pour un prochain débadoc et ça sera
bien sûr avec son documentaire et son
débat à très
[Musique]
bientôt